I'm pleased to be able to reveal the  name of the man who was won the Oscar  for Best Performance by an actor you  will please note that this is not an  award for the best actor but for the  best performance by an actor this year's  nominees are Art Carney for Harry and  Tonto the canoe for Murder on the Orient  Express Dustin Hoffman for Lenny Jack  Nicholson for Chinatown  Al Pacino for The Godfather Part 2  and the winner is the winner is Art  Carney  Thank You Glenda ladies and gentlemen  and members of the Academy what other  words besides thank you  Paul Mazursky and Josh green fell for a  gem of a script particularly from my  wife Barbara and my agent manager father  confessor William Francis Xavier  McCaffrey for 25 years who said two  words to me do it you are old  you